[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: With "Skyfall"
being such a high-profile film
and a franchise, and the whole
50th anniversary thing, the
idea that we had to come up
with had to be completely
slick and on brand.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Well, one day,
me and my credit card number
were talking about a motorbike
scene that everyone was really
excited about.
What can we do to actually
engage our audience using this
motorbike scene?
Because it would be really cool
to actually draw out a
motorbike online.
MALE SPEAKER 3: The main
complication that really kind
of pushed the boundary out,
was the dual screen
technology, the fact that you
could actually use the mobile
phone as the controller and,
obviously, the fact that it's
actually being played inside
a YouTube masthead.
Trying to get that underneath
the file size--
and we made the game
actually playable--
yeah, it was a challenge but,
I mean, it was one that we
managed to overcome.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Get the
technology working first
before you start.
Find the creative-looking
feel.
Partner up extremely
quickly with
double-clicking, as usual.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Basically,
don't give up.
If you think it's gonna
work in your mind,
just push for it.
MALE SPEAKER 1: And make sure
everybody knows what you're
trying to achieve and what the
output is, and what the
performance deadline is.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You
have deadlines.
MALE SPEAKER 1: And when
your deadline is.
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC PLAYING]